my body clock and my broody nature has
become a lot more intense since the
pandemic correct same but at the same
time the freedom to roam meet fall in
love and all of that has never been more
shattered and separated and digital and
soulless and it's got so much worse
james smith welcome to the show
thanks for having me back
difficult second album today why'd you
say that well the difference you have a
good debut and then the second one
you've got to keep up with the talent
you know
if you're thinking about films as well
often the second one is never as good as
the first but i've got faith because we
were saying just off there now i've got
a proper setup
i'm sat at a desk i feel professional
i've got a professional microphone i'm
ready yeah so even if what you're saying
is bollocks at least it looks the part
as long as i've got good hand gestures
people watching on youtube and i can
command the conversation using those we
should
like a guy doing the weather like a
weather guide so we've got a cold front
moving in from the north and some
interesting points coming in from the
south so obviously you are now
subscribed to my newsletter like
everybody else should be and in it this
week i identified the percentage of
britons that thought they could beat
different animals in a fight so 45
percent of brits think that they could
beat a goose 38
think that they could beat a
medium-sized dog
18 thought that they could beat an eagle
and then 5 thought that they could beat
a kangaroo what do you think's the
largest animal
that you could realistically beat in a
fight
before we do that we need to set the
ground rules of what victory is
the animal either runs away or it's dead
or it's immobilized
okay because i'm a purple belt in jiu
jitsu so you know if i take the back of
a kangaroo and i've got a seat belt
under over i've got you know control
over that i've got two hooks in behind
the legs no rotational control of the
kangaroo there's not going to be a
verbal tap
so you know
guru's dead i wanna no no i've just got
control just got control i wanna look at
the adjudicator and be like have i won
because if you want me to kill this
kangaroo then you know there's going to
be a conflict of interest there i don't
think many people have been
really looking at the rule set being a
bjj practitioner i need to know the
rules where i'm acute where am i going
to accumulate points with some animals
like a goose i might pull guard slide in
on my bum you know take away the threat
then that goose steps into the guard
next thing you know half guard deep half
get sweep end up on top i think that
most of these animals the advantage
comes from behind but the problem is
especially with a goose and a kangaroo
their reach you're going to have to try
and fight the reach because kangaroos do
that sort of double like the drop kick
thing
and that's going to be that's going to
be challenging for you because you're
not going to be used to striking at bjj
well that's okay because i'll i'll catch
the leg that they kick with and then
we'll do a run the pipe which is a
wrestling move to sit him down so you
know i reckon i could have a few animals
what about an eagle
again the size discrepancy i wouldn't
really know how to go about it and i
wouldn't want to hurt the eagle either
so you know when it comes to
altercations i still think i'd probably
end up running away but i'm not sure if
i'm honest i probably won't you know if
i could fight any animal
actually no i'd say a monkey but they're
way too strong
so i i don't know if i'm honest i'm
really not sure
66
of brits think that they could beat a
house cat which means that 34 think that
the house cat would win that that really
concerns me like a cat is literally
designed to be drop kicked over a fence
it's the exact size it's the perfect
distance off the ground if you can get
it laterally how far do you reckon you
could kick a cat
20 20 meters easily yeah
have you heard uh have you heard of the
saying that dead cat still bounces
uh yeah i don't know what it means
though so like uh when people are on
their way out of success
right they they say like you know you
could still book them for an event you
know let's say you find someone from
uh a hit to you what was too hot to
handle right the first season you could
still get one from someone from season
one put them in a uh nightclub in
windsor
and they would still sell tickets
they're a dead count a dead cat it would
still bounce if you drop it from enough
height okay so how far it falls it's
still gonna bounce and the the kind of
adage as i believe it is that uh yeah
you can still get a dead cat to bounce
if you drop it from enough height did
you know that the terminal velocity of a
cat is non-fatal
that's uh that would make a lot of sense
seeing as they've jumped from buildings
and
it it's mad have you seen there was a
video on the internet today a guy
jumping out of a window of like a fourth
fifth story floor
hit the deck hard and just got up and
legged it how he how he what did he land
on like grass or pavement like grassy
grassy kind of slippery slope onto
concrete but his butt hit the ground
like if he broke his tailbone it
wouldn't have surprised me yeah but the
adrenaline he got up and run and the
police officers come around a few
minutes later and they're like no way no
one could have survived that it was like
some park or [ __ ] you know when you see
him leap from buildings and then just
land and roll um but yeah getting back
to your question if it was first blood
then a cat could win versus a human
quite quick
um actually little needle claws
yeah i've i've invented uh something
called dog guard which is when i sit on
the floor and i try and take a dog's
back uh because of the nature of them
having four legs uh is and you don't
want to hurt the dog there is certain
techniques you need to use when fighting
with animals but what different breeds
of dogs have you tried this on
uh labrador mostly i know rspca are
there they're ready right now yeah ready
to get us incriminating ourselves the
thing is if you
drive your car later and accidentally
hit a cat they'll come for you
but
they'll say this was uh premeditated
okay
but if if you if you submit a labrador
as long as it's adjudicated and the
labradors signed a form of consent then
it's actually fine
yeah absolutely fine
cool i think that i actually think that
there's probably a potential future for
this sport all right so you're back from
australia now how are you finding it in
the uk
you know what one of the uh things that
i'm celebrating about being back is the
caliber of great guests that i can talk
to on podcasts
uh saying that australia doesn't have
any interesting people in it james i've
just been through them all no i'm not
i'm not saying that like well yeah but
then there's the guests as well
in australia in australia there's
certainly a more limited pool let's say
especially with people that really
interest me um and
it's very great to be in london where i
see that someone's in london hey can we
do a podcast
uh you know in the last four days i've
had two black belt world champions come
on the podcast braulio estema and then
this morning fiona davies i was like in
what world can you just message
two world champions to come on another
chat so that
i'm very grateful for the fact we're
fully open australia's now on full
lockdown uh is great
and uh
yeah it's good to be back and see family
as well do you know what's really bad
people say from a psychological
standpoint when you ask to answer a
question in like bullet points often
it's in the hierarchy of importance in
your mind
james james obviously likes his podcast
guests a lot more than he likes his
family
that's funny what about australia
because you'll have friends and
how ex-housemates and stuff that are
still over there what are they saying
it's like
uh pretty miserable at the moment where
obviously we're only ever shown like the
behind the scenes kind of highlight
wheels of what's actually going on there
so people are gonna be like oh we're
down the beach sunny day blue skies or
whatever but for a lot of them there's
they can't train they've got no sport
they
they're
confined to their houses
there are helicopters going around
saying go inside military have been
deployed to sydney to keep people inside
the fines have gone up to like two and a
half thousand pounds i saw some bulleted
list the other day saying that you can
get huge fines for lying about your
whereabouts lying about contact racing
yeah and there's uh even uh you're not
allowed within a five kilometer radius
of where you live so even if you go to
exercise and do you're allowed outside
of a five kilometer radius of where you
live yeah so like within a five
kilometer radius would be very difficult
because then you'd never be able to go
home you just have all of these
different people like circling apartment
blocks
yeah they they they can do that but like
if you're going to say uh a shop a
walrus that's really far away they'll go
that's not within five kilometers where
you live that's not permitted
so it's very draconian and it must be
quite upsetting to know that you're 18
19 months into a pandemic and you're
effectively at day zero
i mean
the vaccine uptake is about 25 at the
moment why do you think that is
i think that australia didn't feel
enough pain from the pandemic if i'm
honest i think that pain is one of the
most
powerful motivators
uh to you know once you experience
trauma and pain some people fold from it
but other people grow from it
and in the uk there was so much pain
trauma locked down the vaccination was
you know understandably the way out
people took it they didn't want to exist
in do you see the vaccine as folding or
being or growing from it
uh in what sense what do you mean well
you said that there's two ways that
people respond to pain one of them is
folding and one of them's growing and
you mentioned that the vaccine is one of
the outcomes of that do you see the
vaccine as somebody folding from the
trauma or somebody growing from the pain
i actually think it's growing because
it's a risk people are saying okay you
know even i thought
my perspective on the vaccine and the
criticisms of it i thought that gave us
a position to be quite valiant with it
hey you've got something that you're
saying is going to get me out of this
everyone else is unsure put it in my arm
and i mean the people that participate
in those trials
like that is extraordinary
you know nobility from people to go
there and say you know i don't care what
you're saying put that on my arm we can
get out of this pandemic half of them
got a placebo
and i think it's very valiant just the
way that these communities have come
together to go do it i was nervous
getting the vaccine because of the
misinformation that is
touted and i'm i'm
rather evidence-based with my my
thinking i believe anyway and i was
still nervous going there and i was
looking at the sheet of
potential side effects and i'll never
forget
i had a
client in the gym
a very wealthy guy
and he was overworked stressed and his
wife said to me you will never train my
husband unless he has a heart attack and
he has a scare he comes in the next week
he goes all right i i had a bit of a
heart attack i'm going to start treat of
a heart attack bit of a heart attack or
at least a bit of a scare and uh he
trained with me but he didn't really
sort his life out
and as a consequence he suffered belle's
palsy where the side of his face
collapsed and uh he comes in and he goes
i've got two million pounds in my
current account i can't fix this
and that
resonated with me so much that you can't
buy your way out of you know poor health
isn't always visible but something like
that which can happen to healthy people
don't get me wrong
that was a you know randomly for that to
happen he was like doctors weren't sure
exactly what the causation was
i was thinking imagine if that had
happened today
and he's about 50 60 so he would have
been vaccinated 100 he's going to go
look what the vaccine did to my face
and we've suddenly lost
all logical
thought processes surrounding bad things
happening to people
pre-vaccine you know else palsy occurs
adults randomly die sometimes some of
the stuff going on online of people
having like seizures
this happened before vaccines exist and
then people go she was perfectly fit and
healthy she went and got the vaccine two
weeks later this is what's happening and
celebrities are sharing it i'm seeing it
and i'm [ __ ] myself oh no my
vaccine's booked in two days i've had
friends who've had to go for therapy
before they've got their vaccine they've
had to go and sit down with a therapist
so that they wouldn't be
so nervous they wouldn't have an anxiety
attack going in to get it but that's a
really interesting narrative that no one
but very few people have been talking
about
everyone that's been very anti-vaccine
has seen themselves as standing up to
the man that this is the courageous
valiant thing to do but what you
highlighted there there's something
called the tragedy of the commons that
you get with the free rider problem so
herd immunity is required for us to
reach it in order for the economy to be
opened back up if the deaths and the
cases were linked the same as they'd
been a year ago the uk would still be in
lockdown the only reason that we're now
back open is because the deaths have
reduced
the reason that the deaths have reduced
is because everybody's vaccinated that's
what's decoupled cases from mortality
because you get a lower infection load
so on and so forth so you were totally
correct if you are someone that says
okay i understand that in order to get
this country back moving in order to
make other people who maybe can't get
the vaccine to get their lives safe i
need to do something which i know has an
associated risk with it and i'm going to
take on that cost but what you get is
this free rider problem where the person
who decides to just hold out and not get
the vaccine and not get the vaccine and
not get the vaccine ends up benefiting
from herd immunity just as much as the
person who does
but they don't have to take on some of
the potential risks that come associated
with the side effects of it so that free
rider problem turns a lot of the
narratives that people have had upside
down it's like okay so who's the valiant
one like if i'm scared of taking the
vaccine if i know that there are some
potential health risks the same ones
that you do but i'm prepared to go okay
i'm gonna stick this in my arm so that
we can get the country back moving so
that we can get the economy back working
so that people who can't get the vaccine
can actually feel a little bit more safe
at my cleaner my cleaner can't get the
vaccine because she's got some like
ongoing health concerns so the only way
that she could have come back to work in
my house is if everybody in this house
had got the vaccine i didn't just get it
for the cleaner but that's an example
there's also a lot of uh virtue
signaling that's going on from people
not getting the vaccine and you're like
oh you're not you're not better than
people because you've stood up to the
man but i'm in australia it's very
interesting because when i left
queensland
so you look in brisbane gold coast noosa
i had only experienced i think six or
nine covert deaths the entire pandemic
the whole time
new south wales maybe two hundred
the entire packaging
we had 70 80 days with no cases in
transmission
so like we were like oh yeah cover you
know you
you wouldn't have any
the statistical chances of me getting
covered in australia were so small
because no one had it there were no uh
transmissions in the community i
actually got a really bad cold
and when i got really bad cold i was
like no way i'm getting tested because
if i get tested and it turns out i'm one
of five million people that have got
covered i'm done i'll get cancer out of
it out of the country yeah yeah like
james smith uh he covered bastard
there's almost like a shaming like over
here you get tested fine it's normal
it's like you know anything it's just
like oh dave's got covered oh is he i
thought he had it already in australia
when i got the sniffles i was like it's
best not be covered you know and i i
joked around and said to people like if
chlamydia went away in two weeks you'd
never get tested
you just do your own thing keep your
dick in your pants and you'll be fine
right and you someone's like give me a
commitment i didn't know what you're on
about you got it from someone else and
um so i think because of that because
the problem wasn't so severe you didn't
know anyone that died of kovid and i'll
show you your friends your family very
rarely some people are going to go oh
what about the old people i'm a 30 year
old that lives in sydney i don't know
any 90 year olds my family are all in
the uk
so there wasn't enough trauma of people
to be motivated to do it and the
premiere of
queensland actually came out and said
i'm not anti-vaxx but so far i think the
astrazeneca is causing blood clots from
one in ten thousand if you put that
across the population of queensland and
the fact we've only had six or nine
deaths
statistically we're going to have 20
more deaths from the vaccine than we
were covered and she was completely
right
so
you've got that as far as a political
kind of problem australia is still
aiming for a zero covered
you know country
which
is very difficult with the variance
hotel quarantine the draconian nature of
that olympians coming back from tokyo if
you live in south australia you've had
to quarantine twice
two weeks in sydney flight to adelaide
and two weeks in south australia
28 [ __ ] days and now
am i mental here
are we not
in a position where we can get 100
covid test in a quarantine environment
within a shorter period than 14 days
and some people are like oh but some
people don't
have symptoms until day 10 or whatever
take a pint of my blood right do what
you need to do
but if you can determine i've not got it
let me the [ __ ] out you know what i mean
well i had a couple of friends who were
comedians that went over to go and do
tours
and they had to do the same thing and
you just watched someone slowly descend
into madness
as they went over and spent all of their
time in this hotel being delivered sort
of
pre-prefabricated meals that were
already made there thankfully they've
got
a few of them have got quite big
followings they'd managed to get fans to
come and throw weed onto their balcony
from a park that was down below
some people were
throwing like bags of weed and sweets
and like cans and other stuff up onto
the balcony but um yeah i don't know man
it's you can deliver food to the actual
place and say can you take this up so
for instance you get ubereats and
deliveroo
so that comes into the reception it goes
straight up so if you have a food
delivery for your friend
you could put weed brownies so i've
heard in a bag
so i've heard and the hotel will take it
right up to their rooms imagine that
just 14 days absolutely baked out of
your mind you just come out as a
vegetable no kidding though durian went
in uh and he did uh 14 days to come out
for our australia shows he grew 70 000
followers he became
that everyone wanted to know what how he
was losing his mind and for him he's a
very disorganized person being in the
same room for two weeks was perfect for
him
he really
constrained all of the things that he
was getting wrong in his normal life two
of my friends were literally day 13 they
were like i'm not sure i'm ready to
leave you know that
they've got stockholm syndrome keep me
in here exactly yeah they actually
genuinely felt like that for me like
going back and i'm sitting in a hotel
room for two weeks as long as there's
like australia on the other side and i
get to go out and jump in the beach at
bondi
that's fine but
the people having to do it come back to
the uk
having to do it like an ibis in heathrow
not most glamorous of kind of scenarios
but
it is
it's quite depressing i know that some
people in australia wanted to travel to
new zealand where their parents were
very
in poor bids of health there was a case
of one girl who asked if she could go
back and see her mum because her mum was
dying and while she new zealand said
you've got a quarantine and as she was
quarantined her mom died so she said can
i come out and go see her they said no
there was a chance she was going to miss
her mum's funeral but they managed to
push the funeral back a little bit later
and then she went to my mum's funeral
and had to do two weeks on the way back
so she was a month away from her partner
you got people suffering with
bereavement loss of loved ones and
so many people forget that isolation
isolation is the worst punishment given
to human beings
if you go to prison
and you like you know charles uh bro no
bronson charles bronson
done like the most amount of solitary
confinement
if that if you if you are the worst
treated person or you're the worst
person on the planet you are solitary
confined and now we are dishing out
months and years of solitary confinement
to people in prevention of spreading a
virus that's already in the country but
the alternative is to let it run rampant
right it's difficult from a policy
perspective to just say oh well we'll
let it out people don't need to do the
quarantine because you're damned if
you're doing damned if you don't like
this is one of the situations the only
people apparently that knew exactly what
policies should have been done at the
press commenting on something that
happened four weeks ago like perpetually
over the last 18 months they always had
the right answer but not at the time
they had it in retrospect after a month
you're like well
do you really think that
the people in charge of your country
want more people to die like how yeah
i'm sure that some of the people at the
top probably psychopaths and sociopaths
and people that don't have empathy have
snuck through
but like on mass that the entire global
leadership is just trying to decimate
their own countries
it's it's more so the fact that there's
no kind of lateral thinking with this
like i would happily wear an ankle tag
and be on house arrest
i would happily have i would pay
a security a very good wage for two
weeks to stand at my front door and to
make sure i don't [ __ ] leave i'll pay
i'll pay that guy 200 pounds a day she
let me be in a home she let me have a
garden let me have somewhere to sit let
me employ someone to make sure i don't
leave the house you know i mean put
cameras out put a tag on me whatever but
let me live like a human you know
to not get fresh air is one of my
weirdest concerns we did an event in
leeds last week
and there was a room between the
backstage area and the main stage area
and it had no ventilation it was a
really old building and i felt
claustrophobic in it it was a big room
and i said there's no one else bothered
that there's no fresh air in here like
there's no ventilation i panic in those
kind of environments and when you get
into hotels where there's no
window to open for a few hours fine to
sleep fine
but two weeks without having fresh air
come in i already worry what that's
going to make me feel like and some
celebrities if you go there was some
geordie shore cast that went out
and they had outdoor balconies seating
areas their rooms were next to each
other so they could see each other uh
poor charlotte from geordie shore flew
out for two weeks quarantine then the
show got binned because they're outbreak
and had to come back
yeah fully [ __ ] it yeah
so
it's it's quite annoying that's a rule
for one and different rule for another
and you've kind of got to have contacts
in tv if you want to have a balcony but
who have i got suck off to get a [ __ ]
balcony let me know if you can't do it
no one can
exactly then
the sas boys got their own machines on
their balconies i'd like that but just i
probably wouldn't use it
another thing that i've been really
fascinated by recently is sort of modern
dating dynamics especially in the era of
love island and instagram and tinder
relationships seem so
interesting to me especially as women
start to be more educated and outperform
men in employment what have you been
thinking about to do this you noticed
anything interesting
from a dating dynamic um do you know
what it
i know you've had him on the podcast
before jordan peterson the kind of
insight that he has about
intelligent women being
harder to settle they're less inclined
to get married because for a woman it is
often a prerequisite to have a
husband who is more intelligent
that's what they would like and what
they would seek and the more intelligent
woman the smaller the pool for potential
partners
as a counterpart however for men they do
not have that same prerequisite in the
other direction because they have this
macho kind of you know
sense of uh providing and looking after
now
there are going to be some people that
disagree with that you're gonna have
outliers but that's pretty much it on
average on average yeah so now that you
know it that's something the dynamic i
never really thought about before
uh do you know what since we've last
spoken and i actually read a book called
attached
have you read this no so my one of my
ex-girlfriends told me to read it show
nothing
and i left it unread for a very long
time one of my housemates had the
physical hard copy and when i got back
i said right okay i'm gonna listen to it
i'll listen to it start running
and it it's being criticized for not
having enough categories but you have
secure then you have avoidant then you
have anxious so you've got these three
broad categories
and when the traits were
explained i knew straight away i was
avoidant
straight away and i've i've never felt
like i've been spoken to in a book
before
all my traits
and
secure people aren't very omnipresent in
the dating scene because they're in
relationships because they're secure
so if you go into a dating app i've now
come to realize the majority of people
are either anxious or avoidant
now if i start chatting to an avoidant
person we're probably not even going to
kick off because we're both avoiding
there's not enough there
now if i end up finding a secure person
often there's not enough fireworks and
you think they're quite boring and you
go straight past a partner that would
have been a good idea and i've now come
to realize that a lot of people that i
know that are in successful long-term
relationships
the beginning of their relationship was
never special they were friends or they
went on a few dates or they hung out or
they played on the stream they played at
the same rugby club and then over time
it's only month two three and four they
realize how perfect they are for each
other
then you've got this poisonous
avoidant and anxious connection where if
you put an avoidant an anxious person
together there's fireworks in the onset
and i've realized so many of my previous
relationships i've dated anxious women
and it's like two ends of a magnet that
shouldn't be together
and i spot this now when i look at my
friends
if an anxious person is feeling unloved
this mind standing anyway they partake
in something called protesting behavior
and when they partake in protesting
behavior they cause an argument out of
something that never had grounds for an
argument
and they create this kind of protest
because they want to feel loved by the
other person they need re confirmation
of the other persons love them but as an
attack as an avoidant attachment style
myself when i see that protesting
behavior i distance myself from it i'm
like whoa you're acting a bit crazy you
know i'm like
whatever you know what are you doing so
the avoidant person becomes more
detached the anxious person becomes more
crazy trying to get the reaction and you
kind of drift further apart
and then the avoidant person just
disconnects disconnects disconnects and
the relationship goes to [ __ ] and that
is literally probably the last four
serious relationships i've had and i've
read this book and i was like oh [ __ ]
i've been dating the wrong type it was
all here yeah but people confuse the
that sort of flirtation and the little
bit of energy at the start for a spark
right that the
the fact that you have a little bit of
friction that can cause heat this
person's interesting they challenge me
there's something different about them
and then down the line you think well
this is fun for dating but
do i actually want to roll this into a
long-term relationship with someone that
we're constantly at each other's throats
it's a really difficult pill to swallow
to realize that the onset of a
relationship of someone who's not right
for you is amazing
and then it dies out and often the onset
of a relationship where someone's
amazing for you feels quite dull and
people if they're in a stage of their
life where they're dating they might
just cast them aside and move on to
something that feels better and a friend
of mine called me this morning really
angry about like a disagreement it had
with a girly thing and i said
you're i said you're an anxious person
you're partaking and protesting behavior
and i said you haven't got the reaction
you want from her and now you're mad and
venting to me okay the fact you're
speaking to me is because you're so
annoyed she hasn't given you the
reaction you want and i was like [ __ ]
i've read one book about deaton and i'm
already now seeing things differently
you know like when the first time you
find out about macros protein carbs fat
it's like i look at things like that now
i'm like i see the code i see the
numbers the red pills pure red pill [ __ ]
like um so that that helped me
understand a lot about myself really and
the dating scene where i am avoidant and
i have a theory that
being successful in whatever line of
work you do gives you a permit to be
extra avoidant because if something's
not working out or there's an argument
or i start distancing myself from
someone because they're protesting or
they're annoying or there's no
compatibility similar to yourself
we have work we can fall back on
a constant variable that's always there
supporting us
and
you're seeing someone right now right
correct
let's say she starts making your life
hell the demons occur in your head going
[ __ ] you if i get rid of you i could do
an extra podcast every day
i can develop my business
what i do and my legacy if i eradicate
you and replace it with work well
there's a comfort zone there right
there's always this fallback plan
there's always something there that you
know that you've got going on it's
actually kind of like being in two
relationships at once
it is it's like being in a relationship
with the person that you're seeing and
also being in a relationship with your
work
and knowing that if that one starts to
piss you off that you've got something
that you can put your love and your
energy and your attention into and you
will get love and energy and attention
back
and um yeah i i think that
it makes for a very interesting dynamic
when you have somebody that doesn't need
the partner
and i suppose that a lot of attachment
probably comes from a place of
insecurity
and
also if your ego gets hurt a little bit
and you don't want to swallow that
you can just quite quickly even if it's
even if it's not an insecurity you can
just think well [ __ ] it i'm just going
to focus on something that i actually
can predict because that was completely
irresponsible of them to say
yeah and then you can uh such as myself
go and put out good content make video
and you can get your almost addictive
dopamine
serotonin hits from a digital device
which is [ __ ]
now i'm in a position where you know i
could
go cold shoulder
on the person who's giving me grief
where really in a relationship argument
should be a time where you know a bit
like
training a muscle you create damage it
comes back stronger create damage come
back stronger and you're progressively
overloading and that trauma that occurs
is a part of the growing process but
it becomes so easy when you are you know
successful in your own right when you're
working for yourself let's say actually
because that's probably the metric of
success i'm using so easy to just turn
your way on that and go to the other
relationship and then you go oh and this
is the dangerous assumption you're like
if i do that and make more money and get
more successful i can set up for my
future
life my future life my future list and
having talking about a utopian version
of a future wife is a classic trait of
an avoidant attachment style and i was
like when i was like that was oh [ __ ]
i wanted to move back to australia build
the business get the family buy the dog
do this thing they're all justifications
for why you don't need to put up with
difficulties in the now
and that is classic avoidance though and
i thought that was just me and then i
realized that everyone of the same
attachment style was the exact same
and i was like [ __ ] and i've actually
used that sometimes to
create distance between former lovers
where i think i'm a future wife ain't
gonna act like that she isn't gonna say
that she isn't gonna behave like that go
on get out of here you know i mean so i
realized that a lot of these kind of
flaws that exist in my in my thinking
towards relationships is based on
how i am and that apparently is governed
from how you're brought up
but
you need to have variation in attachment
styles as part of like evolutionary kind
of traits you need these kind of
outliers who if i i always think as if i
was a primitive human i was like i'll be
out killing wildebeest and [ __ ] bringing
back legs of meat and
pillaging
through all the women in the in the camp
you know like
i i probably would quite like to just go
hunt on my own and i was like that's
probably why i'm you know i like working
on my own i like i'm very much an
ambivert i have my extrovert moments on
my introvert moments and
uh
in the digital age with social media
it's never been easier
to be
you know introverted and avoidant and
still yet hit quotas and all the things
that but you get to be extroverted on
your own terms
you get to pick when it is that you do
it and this is one of the reasons why i
love doing the podcast that if i was uh
i'm good buddies with mike thurston as
an example and he's
pretty much
constantly vlogging if he wants to put
out two or three videos a week he
actually needs to capture quite a lot of
content he needs to do [ __ ] he can't
just sit down have a conversation he
actually has to do [ __ ] he has to go on
a boat or go to the gym with larry
wheels or [ __ ] do whatever buy a new
car so he has to do stuff and he's
constantly on
always
always on but that suits his personality
types he's sort of this quite gregarious
outgoing sort of like dude who's super
extroverted and always has buddies
around him i'd be like [ __ ] man like i
need so last week i was in london and i
did
uh rebel wisdom on wednesday i did load
to see this podcast on friday i spent a
full day with my buddy alex o'connor
cosmic skeptic uh on another day and
then on saturday i did gb news it's like
i literally for the first time in as
long as i can remember i spent four days
and maybe
like an hour a day
waking was on my own and the rest of the
time was around other people and i came
back on saturday night and i was
completely wrecked like this is
i mean it was awesome and fun but i
needed that time to sort of rest and
recuperate and um yeah designing your
life and whatever your creative pursuits
are and the job that you have and the
sort of partner that you're with around
okay where do i get my energy from do i
have a partner who constantly needs me
if i'm someone who actually enjoys their
time on their own then that's not going
to work because i'm always going to feel
like they're pushing and they're being
needy when i actually just require a bit
of space
i think that
reading that book and really thinking
about what i've learned i've realized
that
the the
real issue is that i've never
communicated my requirements and needs
to be on my own and if i'd communicated
that better when i had gone to that
place of needing to be on my own the
partner i was with wouldn't have felt
unloved because they would have
justification why it's
yeah so i think the next time i'm in
that kind of place i need to say to
someone hey look i need time on my own
now and then
do you know what a lot of the times that
my relationships have combusted is when
i've spent too much time with people
trying to please them you know
letting them stay around all the time
because it's convenient for their gym
routine letting them stay around because
you know of whatever it is and then i've
realized that i've been neglecting my
own attachment style in a bid to make
someone else happy and because of that
it's just blown the relationships up and
now in retrospect i can see that my most
successful relationships are when my
girlfriends live further from me and i
was like [ __ ] i was like
i need some [ __ ] good therapy if i
move in with someone i know man well
there's a few things that i've been
reading about recently one of them is
the cohabitation effect which you may be
familiar with if you live with somebody
who you are intending on getting married
with for more than six months before the
marriage there's a statistically
significant increase in the chances of
divorce so most people this goes against
what most people would think you move in
together you work out if you're
compatible and then you make the
relationship down the line more likely
to work but there's something going on
and there's a bunch of different
theories one of them is this open door
policy the presumption is that if you
decide to live with somebody before
you've committed to them legally and
made it marriage material
you're basically saying you're good
enough
for now you're good enough
right now but i'm not going to commit
just yet we're living together but i'm
not going to commit just yet and that
there's this sort of subtext that comes
through there's a whole bunch of other
suggestions but um that's one of them
another one that i've read about is that
in a relationship where the woman out
earns the man
there is a 50 percent increase in
chances of divorce
there is also a 25 percent increase in
the chances that the man needs to use
uh sedaphanil or viagra to perform in
bed
and the [ __ ] the [ __ ] i know and the
final one was if you have a master's
level education versus a bachelor's
there's a 93 increase in right swipes on
tinder
really yeah one so one year one year of
your life just labs if you're listening
if you're 21 and considering going on to
do a master's increase even if you're
not bothered about the degree 93
increase in right swipes on tinder or
just lie about it i mean that's an
alternative is that in the profile where
it talks about education or is that just
from how the person dresses persona no
it would be in the i think it would be
stipulated in the profile description oh
and [ __ ] lie about it i lied about
him in the bsc for [ __ ] four years in
the corporate world
they just wanted someone with a bsc they
wanted someone with that attitude and i
i had that attitude when i was at work i
only got a foundation degree
which is
these degrees
but then i think that men hugely
underestimate the sapiosexual nature of
women as well what does that mean
uh women that ordinary people that are
sexually attracted to people with
intelligence
stapiosexual that's if i if i uh when
i'm presenting a talk and i do something
that's really kind of profound
and there's silence as they're absorbing
it i'm like yeah ladies the term is
sapiosexual if you're finding me
attractive right now
i i guarantee that the women i think uh
and again
people people say oh why is a man
explaining how women feel and if you do
feel that way [ __ ] off um i've dated
women for [ __ ] 15 16 years i think i
have an insight to it i've made a lot of
mistakes i have a very very good insight
into what women do and don't like in
relationships perhaps more women than
most women so relax all right and um i
would say that women are attracted to
whit and banter and all of this but i
think it's because if you
look across the scale of things
funny people are intelligent very
intelligent i think the people that have
got witty quick banter even the fact
that you could get a joke around quick
people see that as a source of
intelligence an immediate demonstration
of intellect correct
and that must be uh you know an element
of sexual attraction because not only do
you want the kind of
physical
you know uh traits in in someone and
testosterone profiles androgens growth
hormone reproductive whatever you also
want someone who's intelligent and the
same goes
more so for women than men men go for
women but then again
that's often misconstrued that men
obviously then don't find intelligence
attractive and they just want tits or
ass or whatever [ __ ] middle england
likes to put in your questions box you
know hey guys ask me anything
intellectual level tits or ask [ __ ] you
know that was something i found really
weird so when i went on love island
first season and they said what's what's
your type what they were asking was do
you like petite girls do you like
brunettes do you want green eyes or
brown eyes do you wanted to dress like
this they weren't asking what are the
fundamental characteristics that are
going to never change across time they
were saying what are the physical
characteristics that are going to fade
within the next eight years
that's what they were asking that's a
very dangerous kind of question as well
when you put it like that fade over the
next eight years
and another phenomena is
the amount of people that
i've met and found them very sexually
attractive after a couple of hours and
thought wow if i'd only seen a
screenshot of you i might not have
swiped right on you
alternatively the polar opposite where
i've swiped right on someone based on
their picture and met them and there's
been nothing so this is something that
the in-cell community has a huge problem
with at the moment so recently we had
that shooting in
not new key in plymouth
uh i got shouted out for putting new key
in the newsletter by someone from
plymouth by someone from new key and
said that i defended their entire town
um
one of the problems that the intel
community has is that
online dating
platforms like tinder has allowed women
to constrain their potential dating pool
with what are essentially arbitrary
metrics so they can say
on certain dating platforms apparently
you can put in your height and then you
can also restrict your matches by height
so if you're a five foot eight guy and
the woman says nobody before below five
foot ten you lit you do not get to look
in with that woman but what it misses
off and the argument from the insult
community is that
there are x factors grace
you know the way that somebody moves
like the fact that they have good body
language all of these things that you
cannot put your finger on and these
aren't quantified on an app now
something tells me that the in-cell
community isn't exactly swimming in x
factor and and grace but the argument
still makes sense
when um i first started online personal
training before i had an app i would get
my clients
they as soon as they paid i would send
them a video i go hey thank you very
much for joining online personal
training platform really excited to get
working with you i require you to send
me a video back for the first six months
i just started chatting to them but i
didn't know them
that one video that they would send me
they'd be like hi my name's trisha or
whatever it was i could see their level
of anxiety their way that they held
themselves the way they spoke and that
gave me a good idea of building their
program and if they seemed like very
anxious and very they're handshaking no
camera presence i was like
probably not gonna have a squat rack in
their first phase of programming because
if they are nervous holding up a phone
to me i'm not sending them into the
depths of the squat rack and then
alternatively if someone was bubbly like
hi james yeah so i do group classes
every week i'm like she's going to be
fine going in it was amazing that just
45 seconds of someone on camera i could
develop an assumption for who they were
and what they were like
and
where i have used dating apps before
with caution
one of the first things i do when i take
the conversation to whatsapp's like i
want to see you speak
i wanna i just wanna i wanna see
and there's often an unfair [ __ ]
balance if they follow me on insta
because i was like hey here's 400 hours
of me chatting [ __ ] i just want a
[ __ ] 30 second whatsapp video to make
sure that you're not facetuned and
[ __ ] you know what i
mean yeah yeah it's an interesting one
we were talking as well before we
recorded about the
interesting
lack of a stereotype or an archetype for
a young guy in his 30s who isn't married
doesn't yet have a family but can't wait
to be a dad
i'm fascinated by this i think it's such
an interesting time for men
who perhaps have
freedom and liberty to to do what they
want with their life maybe they've got
more resources than they actually need
and
from the outside
you look at those guys and it would be
the dan bilzerians of the world that's
like the archetype of the guy in his 30s
or 40s who's still sort of got it all
but i think both me and you agree like i
can't wait to be a dad i actually cannot
wait to become a father i think i'm
gonna be an awesome father i think i
would have sucked as a dad at 23 24
years old i would have been
like just awful like there should be
some sort of license that you need or
like some sort of test that you have to
pass and i would not have passed uh you
have to [ __ ] test to drive a car why
can't you do it it'd seem to have a kid
a lot more damage to the community with
the family
with the car correct and um yeah i just
think it's it's such an interesting sort
of time to be alive where you've got
these sort of dynamics this sort of
freedom and
no archetype for a man a woman hits 30
and everybody sort of starts side-eyeing
her about oh sort of tick-tock
biological clock when you're going to
get married but for men it's like oh go
on mate like you must be loving it still
being free and liberty and stuff like
that and you're like well
kind of but on the flip side i also want
a family
yeah and uh i think there's another
interesting statistic that i always keep
in mind that the average guy marries a
woman four years younger the average
woman marries a guy four years older
another peterson one i might i'm so glad
i hadn't read his stuff before i wrote
my book some ways it would be so peace
and leaning
um
but yeah it's so interesting you kind of
say about that and i did a psychedelic
trip earlier on this year and
did some mushrooms sat on the edge of a
cliff in north bondi and just thought
about life listen to some hanziman and
when you take psychedelics and a lot of
your ego is stripped away because i find
that
having a certain amount of money certain
amount of recognition success in
whatever fields really shrouds your
vision from
often your values that sit underneath
what actually matters yeah yeah and i
was thinking uh strip that away
what have i really got and i had this
conversation with paul lima a few weeks
ago where i said
i sat there the first thing i thought
about this i [ __ ] love psychedelics
the first question that my mind put on
to me was do people like you for who you
are or what you do
and i had to sit with that
i was like whoa
if you took away everyone that likes me
for what i do
how many people like me for who i am
as a percentage
point fractions of a percent right
and i was like oh it's quite a tough
build swallow sat with it for a few
hours
went through the playlist
and then the second one was
my family's biggest if i was to say to
my mom and dad what you're most proud of
in life
i think they would say me and my sister
ah no question about it
and i thought
huh
i've come through that door the family
house
a lot of times in the last 10 years and
i'm sure they're chuffed to pieces with
sunday times bestseller you know chuffed
pieces that you did this came back first
class from sydney i was like and
actually i bought my dad a porsche i
bought my family a porsche earlier on
this year my uh my dad picked me up from
the airport in a rented van
and i was like we gotta sort this out so
um i went i bought him a portion he was
chuffed to pieces and he he messages me
and what's up he goes son i've never
been so happy behind the wheel of a car
and i was like that makes me feel proud
but i reckon the day i come home with
the wife and kids that's when they're
gonna be like you've done it made it
done it and
i i was sitting back with that and i was
like
my parents are quite similar to me in
the sense where they don't really care
about flash items or or big things and
my mom and dad don't travel i can't even
really take them on holiday you know
even if i was taking somewhere possibly
like down the south coast in the uk
which you can't do in the pandemics
everything's but
you know they're the happiest things for
them in life is
seeing my nephew going to see my sister
at work going out for a sunday roast or
whatever i was like [ __ ] if i really
want to impress the most important
people in my life i'm probably gonna
have to have a family and i was like
the [ __ ] what what am i doing if i was
to you know
look at a spider diagram of my life
there are some parts of it they're
extremely successful but other parts of
it they're extremely lacking
that psychological experience really got
me thinking and when i do talk to people
like oh my you must do so much shagging
but you get loads of birds i'm not me
i'm actually trying to work and develop
an area of my life that i'm lacking
[Laughter]
it's tough because you do get pulled in
so many directions and your mind wanders
and you're like oh maybe
i do want that and then part of your
mind goes maybe you don't maybe you're
designed not to maybe you're not going
to get on with it my track record of
relationships is dire mine's not
fantastic either now
for some reason there's this illusion in
my mind i'm just going to meet the one
and then oh everything changes but
is that probably an illusion is that a
utopian desire
is you know i'm am i
am i so hardwired and programmed
i'm 32
my life revolves around my work my
routine and my training
it's going to take a lot of effort
for me to change that up and it's quite
concerning like
we all just see a few years time in our
family life kids
there's a lot of work that needs to
happen before that becomes a reality and
i think i'm quite
negligent of
giving enough mental attention to that
amount of work required
i think one of the challenges that
everyone is going to have to come up
against that's in that situation you
know the the pt's that are listening the
people that work for themselves that run
their own businesses that do whatever
feel liberated
you're going to have to concede that
your performance at work will likely
have to take a hit in order for you to
have a family like there is a price for
you to pay
you know if you want to court the girl
of your dreams if you want to start the
family if you want to you're gonna have
to take time off work like what happens
vast majority of people anyone that's
read the emyth by michael gerber like
most people don't have a business they
have a highly leveraged solo pursuit
like if they left their business for two
weeks all hell would break loose like
that means you don't have a business
it's just you but you just leveraged a
little bit more and
you're gonna have to deal with that
you're gonna have to deal with
existentially you're gonna have to deal
with the ego like okay
i'm not going to be able to
post
videos as frequently because i'm up at
four in the morning looking after the
kids or i've got to support the wife or
we're in hospital in labor for [ __ ]
48 hours or whatever whatever goes on
like
these are things these are prices that
you need to pay and if you've attached
such a sense of self-worth and you've
wrapped your ego around your success
your externalities of your success
i wonder how many people
without the right amount of self-work
will end up low-key resenting their
family for taking away from them
something that they previously used to
get a sense of fulfillment from
that's exactly the word i was about to
bring in this i'm worried about maybe a
future self-represent you know oh before
this i did more i had more could afford
more had more freedom i haven't
freedom's taken away we've had a lot of
that in the last couple of years
you know this utopian desire of having a
family i'm like oh
you know could i flip a coin and be the
other way around i did a dangerous
poll on instagram once saying
if you could go back and have kids would
you have it was 50 50. 50 yes 50 like
what's the [ __ ] thanks thanks for
helping
[ __ ] the bed i was like maybe i'll just
be a solo warrior my whole life but you
know
uh the funny thing is that we talk about
dumbbells area
in uh in my most recent i won't give it
away too much in my most recent talk i
differentiate pleasure and happiness i
think dan bilzerian fills his life with
tremendously high amounts of pleasure to
fulfill just a
speck of happiness
whereas you know other people have
no [ __ ] pleasure at all their kids
wake them up and they [ __ ] resent
their wife they [ __ ] tired all the
time but they're happy and
uh there is gonna have to be a trade-off
at some point for a lot of people i've
done pt seminars before where
people will say to me like oh i wish i
had what you had i wish i had the free
time wish i had this and i'm like
you're married and you've got kids
they're like yeah i'm like well i've won
some things you've won others yeah i was
like you probably wouldn't trade yours
for mine at this stage i wouldn't trade
mine for yours none of us is a winner
there's no scale here it's not like 100
grand in the bank equals the same
pleasure as one kid or whatever that's
the thing man like most people don't see
the prices that you have to pay for
success and you said it earlier on
certain areas of your life have
hypertrophied and other areas have sort
of atrophied or maybe never even existed
and um
yeah you don't see like i always use
this example of tiger woods like you
don't know the price that tiger woods
had to pay to be tiger woods on the golf
course an absolute animal perhaps one of
the best ever i wouldn't take
relationship advice from him but i don't
think that he's you know he's got such
low self-worth that he's been pulled
over at the side of the road for falling
asleep at the wheel as he's on his
medication he recently rolled his car
i'm gonna guess that he probably wasn't
fully sober when he did that and that
snapped both his legs he spent nearly
half a decade out of the sport
because he's had injuries because he's
pushed himself so hard because that's
what was drilled into him by his father
all right do you want that like do you
really want that because everyone looks
at him and thinks oh great i'd love to
be tiger woods traveling the world
playing golf night contract all this
money adoration
okay
do you want to not be able to look
yourself in the mirror do you want to
not be able to love a wife do you want
to not be able to stay faithful to one
woman those are the prices that you have
to pay but because we applaud success
and we put it on such a narrow domain
such a narrow channel and we put it on
such a high pedestal you think right
that's what i want because that's what
everybody else seems to think is cool to
want so therefore everyone just starts
memetically copying whatever it is
that's on the top of that but the grass
is always greener with this stuff you
know me and you two two guys who could
go anywhere in the world could work from
anywhere in the world are both saying oh
isn't it interesting thinking about
families like wouldn't it be i wonder if
i'm going to be a good dad like i wonder
what sort of [ __ ] like family suv i'm
going to like i mean like what sort of
stroller should we get and um
the grass is [ __ ] greener with this
stuff
like to look at you and say you've got
it sorted mate it's just it's not
reminded
it's also uh here's a
plus four uno card uh i'm adopted as
well so i've never
seen or been with or touched of a
bloodline relative
so if i have a kid
that is going to be the only relative
that's in my bloodline
crazy yeah so like that's another really
crazy like
plot twist on that where
people look around their family they can
see their features and their parents and
their sisters and everything i've never
had that
so that's another kind of layer to it
and sometimes uh
men
right now
are not in the best place they've ever
been for fertility and for sperm count
and for environments like i'm pretty
sure that
as we go through the next 20 30 years
where i think there'll be a natural
decline of uh population due to the fact
of women being more educated
contraception all of these things more
likely to be in professional work life i
think we're also seeing
uh generations of less and less healthy
men
and more obesity more lack of sunlight
all of these things
and i sometimes worry about fertility
you know like it's a weird thing that
when i'm 32 i got hit in the nuts in jiu
jitsu the other day
i was like
it's like [ __ ] i was like don't do that
again i was like yeah i haven't had kids
yet
i was seriously thinking the other day
because someone had commented and said
that um the quality of male sperm
decreases so not well also the volume
but the quality in terms of fertility
decreases in your late 30s and i was
thinking i was going to google it
where can i freeze
some jizz like where can i freeze them
just you know just in case just as an
insurance
it's that policy
it's a valid thing it's 100 a valid
thing and like yeah like
because then i was thinking i was like
if i was infertile which people think is
really rare but my mum and my mom and
dad couldn't have kids so i've lived and
grown up with perfectly normal human
beings they've got no
bids of health
for the amount of wine they drink and
the fact they've never been to a gym
they're [ __ ] amazing
and then they couldn't have kids and i
was like [ __ ] and then i was like
imagine if i was in a position where i
couldn't that means that my bloodline
would never ever continue and there
would be it's not like it could branch
through you know my sister or anyone
else or my parents or whatever i was
like that's it that's it done
the lone gene pool that existed through
myself that never billion years of
unbreakable unbroken survival and
reproduction
would die
yeah and i was like i'll be [ __ ]
and then
uh paula lima one of my favorite people
i had him on the pod a few weeks ago
he
nearly died a covered quite literally
nearly died and
he has two daughters
loves him to pieces and he said there
was like a little bit of solace when he
thought was laying on the floor waiting
for the ambulance to come get him
he was like it's okay
i'll they'll be they'll be fine the
genetic prodigy has uh continued yeah
yeah and i was like there's something
about that i don't think it's really
discussed about it's not it's not quite
macho
to really talk and epitomize
reproduction and there definitely is
something in the body toxins 30 to 32
which annoyingly my body clock and my
broody nature has become a lot more
intense since the pandemic correct same
but at the same time
the freedom to roam meet
fall in love and all of that has never
been more
shattered and separated and digital and
soulless and it's got so much worse and
for me i have a great [ __ ] fantastic
life and i'm very worried about other
people that would be in this exact same
existential anxiety of where the world's
going and when things will be
back to normal and you know
how many people that would have been on
fates path to meet each other and fall
in love and go on romantic trips and
meet backpacking in thailand bump into
each other and split in croatia meet
each other on a [ __ ] boat you sail
week how many of those have just been
squandered and ended up sitting on their
[ __ ] sofa watching netflix instead
it's
crazy that this the dynamism of the
human
kind of petri dish has been frozen for
two years
and i feel like i'm in the middle of it
and i feel like age is just ticking away
i was 30 when this pandemic started i'm
now 32
and i don't like that
hormones are a hell of a drug man i was
saying this the other day to carl
benjamin down south he's got three kids
and like a fourth on the way my business
partner's missus is
three days overdue on her third on their
third their first order they got two
boys that the first thought is on like
literally [ __ ] in the oven ready to
ready to be taken out now
and um
for years kids were the things
that stopped my friends from seeing me
on a saturday when i wanted to to go out
and have breakfast and i was hungover or
whatever they made too much noise when i
was on a plane and i was trying to sleep
and they were just sort of icky and they
got in the way and now i look at young
kids toddlers or babies and i'm like bet
you're cool
yeah you do like
i bet you do like funs i bet you do like
quite fun stuff i'm like
who's this like who's this existing
inside of this head like get out like
you weren't you weren't here before i
don't know who you are
it's uh it's interesting as well then
you've got this huge kind of utopian
picture of
meeting the woman
and there being a perfect time for her
to be the mother of your kids or a wife
and this is a gray area as well
anyone you meet that's happily married
or has kids
there was never a right time
if you were to ask me about business and
ask me the right time is i'm like
there's never a right time just [ __ ]
do it correct the course along the way
yes in relationships you're unable to
take that same advice
yeah but i'll just wait i'll just hang
fire i'll just hang five for the next
one i was thankful for the next one
maybe the problems hurt again
yeah
and this relationships aren't very fixed
business i'm very growth so i've got
similar mind completely different
mindsets and like
if anyone says thinking i'm launching a
business i'd say if you're ready for the
business you launch too late
but then the relationship
yeah hold on boys
and like uh i know i suppose to add on
top of that i know that myself and
probably thousands of british and irish
people in australia
are struggling with visa status
and you don't even know if you're going
to be able to go back properly right
yeah i'm in limbo at the moment and for
four years now
four years which is over 10 my life i
feel like a plane circling ready to land
that's how i felt
because i want to live in australia i do
not want to live in the uk i do not want
to have a serious relationship in the uk
so that's another thing so if someone
here was like james let's go on a date
i'd be like well i really don't want
this to work out i've already decided in
my head i don't want this to work uh and
then someone goes oh but if you like him
you can take him to australia i can't
get myself in you know if i can't get
myself in you're [ __ ] uh it could be
another year before i even hear back
from my decision on pr which might not
even be a yes it takes me to 33. so
there are so many british people and
irish people in in australia
but aren't sure where they live they
they go to bed in australia but they
have limited amounts of time before they
might have to come back and
if you're the type of person like me
that goes there and you go this is where
i want to be home
nothing else really cuts it people go
you might like america you're like well
i don't want to live in america oh i'm
sure you'll love it the beaches are
amazing in l.a you're like yep i don't
live in l.a oh you should just go to
europe you're like what and have no
friends and somebody nice in europe like
so
this whole kind of limbo at the moment
i'm not giving myself permission to be
happy in the uk because it's not where i
want to be you do know that that is a
very good coping mechanism though that's
a very very good get out of jail free
cards that allows you to continue your
avoidant behavior
oh yeah it's the classic trait of the
avoidant
but for me because it's justified it's
justified by something which genuinely
exists like this is a it's a compelling
narrative it genuinely is
but on top of that it's a very
convenient narrative for you given your
particular attachment style
oh yeah yeah i'm aware of that but i'd
rather be wrong in australia than right
in the uk
so like uh
yeah and and and to be fair like
you're always in this constant battle
where like i was hung over the other day
i go see my parents i was like this is
nice
but
there's i'm john i'd love to be wrong
i'd love to go to oz move there for
three four years and go i had it wrong
i'd love to be wrong i want to come home
but for the time being as far as quality
of life
there there's just like
i never appreciated how much i love blue
skies it sounds like such a weird thing
i'm sat here now i'm looking at a gray
sky it's august it's in the uk it's
freezing today absolutely [ __ ]
freezing
and
i've never i do not i discovered a lot
about my values in australia and how
much i love wholesome activities
let me give me some of your favorite
wholesome activities so like uh i would
nap in the afternoon which i do here but
then i'd have a cup of instant coffee a
bowl of cereal and wait for my housemate
cam to come home we'll go swim in the
sea
and go down and i'm my happiest it's
cold in the sea it's wagging yeah yeah
go jump in piss about like jumping
through the waves getting beaten up come
home
like in the morning hey lads six a.m
summarized it no one can deny a sunrise
dip the only thing getting in the way of
a sunrise dip is you not wanting to get
out of bed so then we'll just [ __ ]
pull you out of bed um
and like i lived in a budget house in
australia my rent's like 200 pounds a
week
i lived in a bit of a [ __ ] part of
sydney but i was happy
whereas in london i need to live
somewhere nice i'm living in richmond
living on my own living in a posh area
because
i need to get my happiness from that
because i'm not getting it from outside
the house to compensate yeah yeah
richmond park's lovely but i don't want
to be there after i'm in there for an
hour i'm going for a jog on my arm bored
of this now get me home i watch so much
more tv here um and like although
there's just so many kind of wholesome
parts to me that are unfulfilled here
like i haven't swam in the sea now for
like two months so here's something that
i think a lot of entrepreneurs need to
realize about being in the uk if you are
in the uk if you're somewhere else that
you just don't like where you live
one way to look at that is i am not
being fulfilled externally in some of
the ways that living somewhere better
quote unquote would facilitate me but on
the flip side it's a forcing function
that permits you to spend more time on
work
like if you need to front load the
amount of effort that you put into a
business or growth or your skill
development or whatever it is living
somewhere [ __ ] is actually a really good
forcing function for that because there
are fewer things to distract you now
the argument would be what is the end
goal reason of you being good at the
business it's to have a life which makes
me feel happy so why not just shortcut
it and live somewhere good in the first
place but there is also
i think that you would agree too
there is like a there's an entry
requirement right there's like a buy-in
that you need to get like you need to
get to a minimum level of income and
security with the business and if you
can front load the work that gets you to
that more soon this is one of the
reasons i really want to talk to you
about i know you um
are a little adverse to buying property
that buying property is something that
you're not a huge believer in um and i
was really interested to dig into that
what's your reasons for that
so
first of all uh
a lot of people
can't really afford to buy houses they
can't the majority of people can't
afford to buy houses um the majority of
people in their 20s
should be figuring out who they are and
what they want to do
and they get they get sidetracked so
they get into a job that pays 20k then
it pays 25 and it pays 30.
and they're not working a job they don't
really like for 30k
they then start eyeballing a house
they end up then buying a property
somewhere they don't want to live
it's someone they probably don't want to
spend the rest of their life with so
they can get a mortgage to appease their
parents
they then remain working a job they
don't like to live in a house in a place
they don't want to live to afford a
mortgage with a partner that they don't
want to be with and suddenly they're not
only trapped by the partner
they're now trapped by their job they
can't just leave their job and go start
a career they can't go turn a hobby into
a passion
they now have the pressure of if i break
up with my partner
i'm gonna have to take on the mortgage
payments myself that i can't afford
because i'm not earning enough money to
do so so i think a lot of people are
living in this existential
[ __ ] up
where even if they do break up with
their partner they now need to sell the
house
and any money they did make on the house
has now got to go stamp duty fees
[ __ ] legal all of this [ __ ] right i
think a lot of people fall into that
trap not everyone but when i'm giving
advice to people it's to those people
you know living an hour away from your
[ __ ] job i've got friends now at the
moment i think they're [ __ ] crazy
they're 32
and they're living with the parents of
one of the couple
an hour and a quarter outside of london
to save money for a house
i was like you guys are in the prime of
your [ __ ] life
and you are living in the middle of
[ __ ] nowhere to save money why not
just buy a house in a few years time
when you can afford it
why not just live near your [ __ ]
office enjoy your life you'll get
promoted in a few years time
you'll be all right it breaks me that
people are prioritizing
the agreement on a bit of paper
over their life because at the end of
the day
buying a property is just changing the
belief system and who that property
belongs to
if i buy the property i'm in right now
nothing really changes i still sit here
i still pay money out each week i still
sleep on that sofa i go upstairs into a
bed
but for me to buy this i need to give up
one and a half million pounds or step
into debt for the rest of [ __ ] my
adult life until i pay it off
for me
if i had one and a half million pounds
okay i'll just buy this cool i'll just
buy it be worth a bit more in a bit of
time i'm gonna go to australia i
probably will buy something because i've
got
money that i'm not using that makes
sense
but for people to you know
in your 20s my mum and dad never ever
said to me to get a mortgage this is why
i stand like this like go enjoy yourself
they said actually you know
but my mom and dad slumped paid off
their mortgage but they said when we die
we leave some money you can put it down
and buy a house don't worry about it
enjoy your 20s i enjoyed my [ __ ] 20s
i played rugby in new zealand i went to
thailand on two weeks notice
i went to australia 27 i lived the best
life ever and living my best life put me
in a position to follow my passion and
now because of that i'll probably buy a
house outright and it won't sting when i
buy it i won't need a partner forced
into that position to help me buy it
either
people go renting as a waste
renting is not waste renting is freedom
renting is deciding you on a [ __ ]
move next week
fine
renting is not worrying about mortgage
payments renting is not staying with a
partner that you don't want to be with
just to [ __ ] cover the costs
you pay the price whichever way you go
and for me i love the idea that i might
go
i'm going to america tomorrow the board
is open i don't worry about him to fill
it tenants attendance calling me at four
in the morning when i'm in america james
the boiler's gone oh [ __ ] you know let
me get someone
out there are different people out there
that want different things if you want
to buy a house you're just going to
ignore what i'm saying
but for a lot of people
there are way better things to be doing
in your 20s and saving for a house and
if you do what you want in your 20s you
might just have the money to buy one out
right in your 30s or even your 40s
there's a stat in the happiness
hypothesis by jonathan hate that says
the single biggest determinant of
happiness or the single tightest
correlation that he could find was the
commute to work so the longer that your
commute to work the lower your life
happiness that was the tightest
correlation that he was able to find
throughout his entire research in a book
on happiness so i i i think that you are
right when people buy houses for the
wrong reasons
um i would posit that
for people at the
lower end of the income bracket
and people at the absolute top end of
the income bracket renting for both of
those people makes sense but for people
who are in the middle who are they're
going to be able to make
maybe 10 000 pounds plus
per year over the top of what they need
to live so that they would be able to
save that for me there's no better place
for you to put your money because you're
going to turn cash into an asset that is
going to generate money over time so the
house that i'm in right now i have two
of the housemates that live in this with
me and they pay the mortgage the
electricity the water the rates the tax
the cleaner
the internet and you go okay so now i
live rent free
so i live rent free plus
all of the money that was going into
rent goes into bricks and mortar and
that's equity that's owned by me and all
i've done is rinsed and repeated that so
i've just bought house number five which
is completing this week and it's just
buy to let find 35 grand ish put it into
a three bed house that generates about
800 and something pounds a month
and you go again and you go again and
you go again and over time that
compounds so i understand that for
somebody that really wants freedom and
doesn't have the cash that sits over the
top of that in order to um give them the
the extra leeway that they need that
that would be a bad piece of advice if
you have tons and tons of money then
[ __ ] it it doesn't matter because you
don't need the extra income afforded by
letting properties or by assisting
yourself to reduce your living costs but
for somebody that sits in that middle
bracket i actually think that it's a
really smart potential now this being
said
you need to do it in a city where you're
able to buy properties where the yield
is sufficiently okay london is not this
place the amount of money that you need
to put down on a property versus the
amount of money it's going to earn you
back in terms of your rent is
essentially pointless like you might
even lose money on that property but
outside of that somewhere like newcastle
somewhere up north i think it's a it's a
good potential
so i completely agree with what you're
saying there and what you're doing is
incredibly smart but then the second
caveat point comes in
that that doesn't interest me
and that's not to say what you're doing
is bad is to say that that doesn't
interest me so that people go well
you're a fool because you could be
making this this and this and
for me
when we could sit in armchairs when we
were 65 and you could sit back with more
money than me and go i've got 45 houses
and i could sit back and go
i could have had 45 houses but i didn't
do anything that never interested me
and
i would be proudly sat back on that
little armchair going
i had plenty of opportunities to invest
my money and and do smart things with it
but it didn't interest me and i could be
wrong i could change in five years but
ultimately
i love doing
talks
meets writing books i would rather
say you go james uh you know i bought
this house for 35 grand and then a
mortgage whatever
i'd say i'm going to the maldives uh how
long does 35 grand get me i'll get you
uh 12 weeks sir cool
all right i'm gonna take 10 hardbacks
with me and i'm going to write a new
book and i'm going to get the advance
from that and you know what i mean and
for me
financially that is a worse decision but
over the next year of my life or going
away and doing random [ __ ] like that
i'm i could be wrong with this gamble i
could be so wrong but i can't wait to
just
invest in myself and one day when i have
a farming home i will buy it so that
when i die someone has it and again this
disagreed me on this right
my mum and dad created a comfortable
life for me but they never gave me money
um because they never gave me money i
was in the job center when i was 19
knocking on doors for a living i worked
in a pub on a caravan site when i was
16.
that
was excellent when i look at people that
are given too much by their parents they
don't have the work ethic they should
so like again i have this
kind of mentality in my mind of just
wanting to spend it all i joke around
with my uh
my business partner saying
uh inheritance tax should be 100
so the state gets forces you to finish
it by the end of your life yes spend it
do it live a life get rid of all of it
and then your kids don't get anything at
the end of it so you have to bring up
your kids with that i think that the
same mentality for me
coming from a working class background
not really having money
you know being like literally skinned
bones of my ass couldn't drive myself
home from my placement year at uni back
to uni when the placement year went
kaput but i didn't have the money to put
the petrol in my car to get home and
that was 20 20 years old
and then 13 years later you know being
able to afford five houses and and have
varieties of income and stuff like that
but i think that the
coming from that background of no money
has actually lent me to have like
ambient monetary anxiety
so for me i require a greater sense of
comfort
i need to know what is coming in each
month and the position at which i feel
right fine i'm now liberated to [ __ ] off
to the maldives and drop 35 grand like
it's only getting toward this the place
now where that's something that i would
feel comfortable doing
because
the prudence and the conservatism
financially that has kind of been quite
pervasive especially if you've come from
never having money i do think that we've
got sort of two different role models
going on here one of them is never came
from money it's fine
even if i don't have any it doesn't
matter and the other one is never came
for money [ __ ] i've now got some hold on
to it at all costs and make it earn more
for me
and they're both correct
because they're both they both are in
line with our values and what we find
happy you know what man sometimes i wish
i could love newcastle someone like that
do you know how lucky you are to be in a
part of the world like that and to love
it you love it right it's good it's good
man it is it's
it's a small city that's easy to that's
easy to win at and that was something
that i really really enjoyed i wouldn't
say that it's the best place to live in
the uk
um i've been to you know i do enjoy
london i enjoy being in cosmopolitan
cities and stuff like that but it is fun
it's good night life you get flights in
and out of it you know why i like
i almost wish i never became such a
[ __ ] snob for the good life yeah
because
like
i remember sonny webster good friend of
mine pretty sure you know him like the
olympian lifter
he calls me up one day he goes i'm
having a bad day like come on we're
going for a walk
and we'd walk and i could see the sea
and there's blue skies and the sun and
everything like that
i can't go back from that i can't step
backwards from that life and like uh
if i i probably will be hypocritical
when uh or will be a hypocrite when i do
buy in in australia but then i think
it's slightly different values um when i
go you've been to us no
there's a there's an area called gold
coast and it's on the beach and you get
a lot for your prop for your money there
and i actually want to keep living in
sydney but i actually want to buy a big
four bedroom house in gold coast on the
water not too far from a beach because
then i want to
have an open invite for all of my
friends to come to australia and to stay
in that house so even if i'm living in
sydney i'm like right guys this weekend
come
here's the key code for the front door
come stay with me and if my friends got
families they got kids or whatever
they'll stay in that house even if i'm
in the uk hey go stay in my house over
there
i'd love to create that like community
environment where there's like a cinema
room and something for this and a
barbecue outside
and for me the idea of buying that is
amazing because then i get to park my
money and other people get to use it and
they don't they don't get to feel like
they're getting a hand i'm like yo come
stay with me but that that excites me
but outside of that
my freedom is so important to me and
like i'm not saying that you've
jeopardized any of yours and i always
think in the back of my mind as well
did you ever think that like
during when the pandemic started i was
like if we lose 25 of the population
property prices are gonna [ __ ] that
cryptocurrency is going down
all right if we get another sales
covered three
just saying
it comes out with a with a higher
fatality rate i mean what is the the
plague it's like 25 million or something
something stupid no maybe not 25 minutes
maybe 25 million
maybe something else someone come out
like that chris mate them houses right
tenants gone everyone else gone
more houses than you know what to do
with it's gonna be like the problem in
china having too many men for the amount
of women
just saying mate you know it bricks and
mortar they certainly goes one way until
it doesn't
well it's only gone one way throughout
all of history and whatever it is past
performance is not an indication of
future returns absolutely right that
being said man [ __ ] the people that
trade cryptocurrency and stuff like that
they have balls of steel that's
something that i absolutely could not do
um
yeah i mean the last year house prices
in the uk have risen by their the
highest percentage ever
that's what they want you to believe
i've just paid for one i know that it's
gonna know that it's gonna try a lot
we've got um we've got ifs coming up
this weekend what are you doing there
uh we're getting off to next task no no
no no no no when this releases it is
this weekend in podcast world okay yeah
sorry i've only just started doing that
uh whenever i do a podcast i'm like
let's release it they're like don't
[ __ ] lose it
uh yeah ifs this weekend uh in essence
uh i went to
a fitness expo body power no names
whoops a few years ago
i was like i was like [ __ ] this has
potential to be so amazing like we go to
one area they were like evidence-based
speakers in the smallest little tent
and then you got you know just
supplements down supplement stand
supplement stand topless bodybuilders
topless bodybuilder and i was like this
is [ __ ] disgusting
and i remember uh joking around with my
events team and saying something like
look there's so much scope for this to
be better and they were like let's do it
so i sat down with the organizers i was
like look these are the kind of people
we need to have to attend it and then
they're like okay what about party i'm
like yes i'm a big party so 2019 went
barcelona charlie sloth on the dj set
like it was
lit it was amazing but the core
component of it is business the business
for personal trainers because
there is not enough support or education
for pts to run a business you could be
the best pt in the world but if you if
you're not charging good money
and growing your business you will die
out because even if you're a really
enthusiastic 24 year old charging 50
pounds an hour
if you do not learn how to master
commoditization and demand
or build money online
you're gonna have a family soon and your
family are only going to be home in the
most in demand hours as a pt
and if you do not learn how to work
around that you're pretty much [ __ ]
and to be able to host an event where
you get to upskill personal trainers and
teach them how to run a business with
the best minds in the world and most
people go i haven't heard of the other
five people and i go yeah they're the
ones i [ __ ] learned it from so you
know you got that and then this b2c
element on the outside where
people can come along me and you you're
going to be at the bar having a gin and
tonic someone comes over hey guys love
your podcast which one and then you know
oh classic
and like going around having like drinks
with people i think budgie smuggler were
like trying to do a ninja warrior course
grenada bringing a hot air balloon like
there's panels inside where people can
talk there's a mental health panel
there's a panel on whether or not the
fitness industry is sexist like we got
all these like juicy things and it's not
expensive to come down for the weekend a
lot of people haven't had a proper
festival vibe in quite a while and
yeah it's just exciting and
my events team have done [ __ ] an
amazing job they've got a background of
like music festivals and events so the
production is lit
you go to some places and they've got
like a dj set on
[ __ ] [ __ ] production and [ __ ]
speakers uh so yeah mr jam's playing in
the evening and i don't know if you've
seen mr jam live yeah we've booked him a
couple of times he kills it he is unreal
the energy that guy brings insane yeah
insane so like
i'm buzzing i'll be pulling out the
yellowtain glasses upping about the
dance floors no selfies after 10 p.m
yeah man i'm gastric i'm guest i'm
hosting the podcast panel 3 p.m on the
saturday on whatever the [ __ ] stage that
is
so if anyone is listening
i was supposed to have a link i was
supposed to get some sort of a link if
they just google international fitness
summit yeah.com
it'll come up and get your tickets this
saturday and sunday
and then is there a thing on the friday
are you guys doing a meet up on the
friday
on saturday the first hour on saturdays
and meet up solo travelers so we're
gonna get name tags for all people that
are traveling on their own i'm trying to
get colored name tags so you can get
green amber red i don't want a traffic
lighting one right okay
i'm not sure
so
not sure anyone that wears the amber one
it's so funny like what are you doing
playing hard to get what are you here
for apparently avoiding behavior yeah
yeah apparently club nights at the
moment uh that's a big no-no the traffic
light systems well we do it only on
valentine's day we do it every year on
valentine's day at our events so some
controversy about that people saying
that
oh you can't do that anymore it's
[ __ ] degrading or something like that
not in newcastle man newcastle doesn't
it doesn't fold to this woke stuff
like it's just such salt of the earth
people when you have lads that wear
rigger boots and use the
plaster dust from the work that they've
done during the day to chalk up the bar
before they lift in the gym on an
evening time and they've still got like
their work overalls on and a high-vis
t-shirt like they're not they're not
bothered about gender-neutral bathrooms
and whether or not
traffic light parties are racist yeah
this guy i just got out london i know i
went i went for a coffee earlier and
it's like this toilet is gender neutral
and i was like [ __ ] out just be like
just have a sign saying use whatever one
you want or just toilet you know if they
just
if you wanna cater for all genders or 72
of them and you've got two toilets in a
building that you don't mind people
using just take the m and the f sticker
off right and just have toilet
like
the the over-reaching of the work stuff
[ __ ] me newcastle's never sounded so
appealing i know man i know it really
does help but yeah so international
fitness summit dot com if people want to
go and get the tickets saturday is the
more that sunday's the most sort of pt
side one right it's a more businessy
side one saturday's for everyone party
vibes go around you know panels gin and
tonics big party in the evening probably
activewear by day and then party gear by
night then we're all going to meet up
about 9 9 30 on sunday hungover uh we've
got over 500 personal trainers doing the
b2b on the sunday uh where uh during
myself phil graham paul moore mark coles
uh
jay alderton are doing these uh yeah
business to business talks they're gonna
be like
ted talks about things that probably
people are getting wrong things you can
work around it interactive q a then by
sunday night we can all die and maybe
end up going for a beer
i love it man i'm sick i i can't wait to
go i'm coming down on the saturday
morning i think so i'm gonna be like
caffeinated on the train and
pushing myself straight onto the stage
it's gonna be fun that's it i'm buzzing
for it i'm dust james smith ladies and
gentlemen people want to check out your
stuff where should they go
just to just type in james smith it was
tough at first right when i started i'd
had to say very normie name isn't it
there's a lot of them
yeah but i'm now top of the algorithm
number one james smith in the world
imagine that
imagine being the number one james smith
in the world there's a singer who won't
be too happy about that but
there's a very anti-semitic labor mp
called chris williamson from derby uh
who i'm desperately trying to beat in
google rankings i've got him on pretty
much everything except for just like the
top three on google soon
well they give us a year lad give us a
year and we'll be we'll be top of that
but yeah type in james smith twitter
facebook youtube instagram everywhere
i'm everywhere peace man see you on
saturday thank you mate
thank you very much for tuning in if you
enjoyed that then press here for a
selection of the best clips from the
podcast over the last few months and
don't forget to subscribe
makes me very happy indeed
peace
you